My name is Nick Zammeti
and I'm a YouTube influencer,
I suppose, or woodworker, artist.
I'm going to walk you
through how I restore a
rotting Christmas sleigh.
I was involved in a TV
series here in the UK,
which, I got given the sleigh to restore.
It was brought in from Lithuania,
so the sleigh was pretty old.
I'm not too sure exactly how old it was,
but it could be 100 years old.
I have no idea. But it
was definitely pretty old.
First of all, it's covered in this green,
like a lime-green paint
that somebody's painted,
and I'm not sure if that was
the original color or not.
It's got twisted bars in it.
The metal's all twisted and battered.
Half the seat's missing on it.
So there's there's certainly
a lot of work to do.
First, what I've got to do
is unbolt all of the sleigh.
The best thing to try
with this type of restoration is to try
and unbolt everything I
can, using different tools
because there has been some
different types of nuts
and bolts added to this over the period.
So I'm trying different spanners
and ratchets and sockets
and things just to try
and get everything unbolted that I can.
Now I'm going to wire-brush
the entire sleigh as well,
because I just want to get
off all the rust I can.
I'd say it's probably been
on here for years and years.
So wire-brushing everything
as much as possible.
So, there's bits of the
patterns on the side there,
some bits that are missing in that.
So I'm going to need to kind of recreate
and reconstruct those.
There's an old bit of wood that
I can lose from this to use
to cut out the pieces.
I'm going to have to chop
out a few of the bits
and pieces that I need from
that old bit of sleigh wood.
I'm going to use a jigsaw
to cut out the shapes
for the missing part and then try
and sand it back and glue it in.
What I'm going to have to do to try
and recreate the pattern that's missing
on the other side is just check
out the side that is whole
and sort of trace that
side and then flip it over
and then try and cut out a similar shape
to fit into the missing pattern.
Now I'm going to have to make a seat
for this sleigh, because there
isn't one. It's disappeared.
So I'm going to biscuit-join
the pieces of wood together
to try and make the seat a whole piece.
So, when you put the biscuits in,
I'm going to have to put some glue in
and get it all clamped up
and leave that overnight.
So, now with the seat that's now ready
and all glued up, I'm going to have to try
and rough this up a little bit.
So I'm going to burn it, just
try and make it look a bit old
and sort of, like, in keeping
with the sleigh really,
because it's a new piece of wood.
We've had to make this seat
completely from scratch.
So really you're going
to have to burn it up,
bang it with a hammer a few times,
like it's been there for 100 years.
So, now we're going to have
to sand the entire sleigh
down. As much sanding as possible.
There's going to be a lot
of hand-sanding involved,
and I'm going to have
to use a few machines
like orbital sanders
just to really try and
get as much of this green
that someone's covered this sleigh in,
and also with the metalwork as well,
because it is very rusty
and it's got some really old paint on it.
Going to try and get all
that back to bare metal,
just to try to get off all the old stuff
and preparation, really,
for the new paint.
I want to paint the frame black.
There's obviously few different
ways to paint sleighs,
but I want a sort of
traditional Santa sleigh,
and from what I know
and what I've grown up
to know of is that the
Santa sleigh's kind of,
like, a bit red, obviously,
and it's got some black in it.
So I'm going to go with
the frame completely black
and then start painting all the wood
a nice, bright, vibrant Santa-sleigh red.
The sleigh's going to need
a few coats of this red
because it's going to seep
into the wood quite a bit.
So we're going to need a
few coats of the red on it.
The black's going to cover quite well,
so that's going to come up all right.
And I think with this piece,
it's going to need hand-painting, really,
because there are so many
individual little areas
and little bits that meet
up to the black metal.
I think it's just going to be
easier to just hand-paint it.
It's going to take a lot longer,
but I think the finish is
going to be much, much better.
Now I'm going to have to
use a tiny paintbrush, just
because it's just a bit
more of a detailed section.
I want to make sure I
don't get the paint all
over the other paint that
I've just put on there.
So, I've managed to keep all the aluminum
that's been put around this sleigh.
I'm going to have to
put it all back in now.
Just basically using some new nails,
just hammer and nails, really,
just making sure it's
all banged into place.
And it is that type of aluminum that
you can just bang it and mold
it around the wood and stuff.
So it makes it look quite cool anyway.
Now I'm going to fit everything together.
So I'm going to put the
new seat in that I've made,
get that bolted in and secure
with the backrest on there.
There's a few new bolts
I have to add into this
because some of them couldn't
really get off before.
So, that is the sleigh finished.
The end story to this is
actually pretty amazing.
Because it was part of the show,
I obviously had to sell this sleigh,
and it actually was purchased
by a chap who runs a shop in New Zealand.
So if you wanted to see this sleigh
or actually take a seat in the sleigh,
it is now sat in New Zealand
in a shop called the Christmas Hut.